okay so Amazon Prime's new show The
Citadel has just dropped its first two
episodes and throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down the brand new
show backed by the Russo Brothers this
Studios put a lot into it with the
series apparently costing roughly 42
million per episode this is gonna be a
groundbreaking Global event and though
this is the main series we know that
it's also going to be getting several
local language spin-offs added to the
roster these will take place in the
Citadel universe and have each series
taking famous actors from the country
it's set in and giving them their own
spy story that ties into the main plot
it sounds like a really interesting
premise and Amazon must be very
confident to be launching such a massive
Global series like this but what is it
about exactly well in it we follow
Citadel agents Mason Kane and Nadia sen
as they pull back into the life after a
mission going awry that caused their
memories to be erased I think that the
series definitely wears its influences
on its sleeves and there's lots of nods
to James Bond mission impossible the
Bourne movies and well every Spy film
out there luckily I just so happen to be
an expert on them and though not all of
these might be intentional I will be
talking about where they potentially
pull from and the original work that
inspired them and we start off with an
upside down shot on a train in the
Italian Alps is then rotates around and
we're introduced to Nadia symbolically
an upside down shot like this is
supposed to represent the underworld
which is very much the case with his spy
agency operating under the surface cold
opens are of course a staple of spy
movies as well with this very much
following the format before we cut the
titles and then the rest of the story
now if you recognize the font of the
locations used throughout the series
then that might be because it's also the
exact same one that we use in our
thumbnails little bit of trivia for you
but this font is actually called agency
which again ties into the idea that
we're following secret agents working
for an agency actually chuckled a bit
when I noticed this and it shows how
much thought they put into every aspect
of the show had I not used the font
myself then I might not have noticed it
but it's a great little detail that
really adds to the series anyway there's
trains where we meet both Mason and
Nadia Nadia is introduced wearing a
bright red dress which just so happens
to be the same color as what she's
reintroduced to us wearing in episode 2.
she's very much meant to embody the
classic Femme Fatale which in case you
don't know it's basically French for
lethal A Deadly Woman the dictionary
definition of it is a woman who tries to
outwit others by using her beauty charm
and sexual Allure that's very much the
case here with Nadia and to me she's
echoing several Bond girls that we've
had throughout the years though Ursula
Andress is credit as being the first one
it was actually Eunice gayson who played
Sylvia trench in Dr no she showed up
early on wearing a red dress and this
was later riffed on by Salon Shin Casino
Royale best Berlin 2 also wore a red
dress as did Lupe La Mora in license to
Kill might be a reach on that with the
red dresses but I think what is in the
reach is the classic spice setup that is
a speeding train this has become a
staple of the genre with this game them
and From Russia with Love Live and Let
Die this spy who loved me golden eye sky
falls Specter and many more the first
mission impossible movie ended with one
as well and it's often a quintessential
location to have an action scene at due
to the speed and small corridors that
the characters are confined to Nadia
bumps into a Target in this opening and
it lets us know the two people that we
need to be paying attention to now it
turns out that a guy in the chair is
Bernard Olek who's played by Stanley
Tucci man starts talking about his blood
the bloody ex-wife and we get to meet
her later on and find out why their exes
we also hear about her gadgets including
an explosive perfume and some red
lipstick which no man can resist now at
this point we're introduced to Mason
Kane flicking a lighter and speaking
Italian like the Suave spy he is Sean
Connery is first seen as James Bonds
started off with him sparking a paletta
which I think this moment might be a nod
to however it's revealed that Mason
doesn't actually smoke and he's just
carrying it because he doesn't like
being totally caught bloody idiot and
both are multilingual and would need
this of course to blend into any
environment though there's a bit of
sexual tension we see that Mason has a
wedding ring and later learned that he
has a wife in his new life something
suspicious going on as he doesn't return
till after he loses his memory and we'll
be talking about theories later on about
what might be happening nice bit of
symbolism here and that Nadia has
earrings with two chain links locked
together whereas when we meet her in the
present she just has singular ones might
be symbolizing the pair working together
as a team or it might be a rich now
while Neddy goes off to get the target
Mason goes after his bodyguard leading
to a bathroom fight that Echoes the
black and white opening of Casino Royale
you also get another nod to bond in
Nadia's pistol that she holds up to the
Target this is a silver Beretta and
though Bond eventually ended up using
the Walther PPK the first gun he ever
had in the Box was a Beretta 418 orthane
Fleming actually got a letter from a fan
known as Jeffrey boothroid who said that
he thought that Beretta was actually
more of a ladies weapon bleming wrote
back to him asking if he had any other
recommendations in boothroid suggested
the Walther PPK as a thank you Fleming
included a character gold major blue
throat in the next book who would let it
go on to become known as Q either way
though saying it's a lady's weapon it's
a nice little touch here as we see Nadia
busting it out now the target reveals
and that false information was fed to
lower Citadel out so he could deliver a
message this comes directly from
Manticore which is a beast from Greek
mythology that has the body of a lion
tale of a scorpion and the face of a man
before you start going oh oh that last
one's not so bad Shut the off for a
second yeah shut the up on the
man's mouth yeah it's filled with
shark-like teeth and yeah just an
all-around body on the opposite side of
this is Citadel Sephora fighter location
where people tend to take shelter out
during the middle of a War the group
have shaped historical events that have
evaded them very much tying in with this
name now due to comments at the end of
episode 2 we know that an agent has been
turned to them spring this trap is all
because of a betrayal The Bodyguard goes
out the window which is how tea he was
killed and Live and Let Die with jaws
also going out the window on a train in
the spy who loved me it turns out that
man's corner now the location of several
Citadel agents which have been executed
man also reveals a 10 Ring zest tattoo
and reveals that they have people
everywhere luckily Mason arrives to save
the day leading to a fight on the train
before it all goes to hell and from here
we go to the title sequence which shows
several of their deeds such as a CIA
plot to kill Castro which we also see
failed is the idea that very little are
known about them with us also seeing a
passport for priyanka's character which
says Charlotte this is another name
that's used alongside nadio in the
opening and it's the one that she adopts
in episode 2. there's a flash of Heidi
as well and it's clear that they have
several identities just like Jason
Bourne you also see the logo and get a
quick pop in of what I believe is a
manticore for a Split Second anyway
after this we cut a Mason floating in
the water evoking images of the opening
of Skyfall occurred to him in a hospital
bed and Bellagio which is where we learn
Mason now has Amnesia similar to Jason
Bourne the series centers around him
discovering his past but unlike born
Mason actually makes a life for himself
We join him eight years later going
under the name Kyle in Oregon with his
wife Abby and their daughter Hendricks
mantikora Making Waves with a terrorist
attack in LA and Mason gets flashbacks
of his life when he views them come
roughly the 17 minute Mark of episode 2
we see as more attacks continue to
happen and these are currently rocking
the world now he joined Mason in a
therapy session and we see that he has a
wedding ring however we later learned
that this isn't the one from the start
obviously Abby didn't want to hand me
down and this shows that the pair met
after the train Mission still though
summing causes him to hold on with it
because along with the ladder on
passport it's all that he has from
before his Amnesia Mason feels like he
must have done something bad because no
one's come looking for him and the
therapist then suggests finding his
family through a DNA database this
eventually flags up to Bernard who has
to pull him out of hiding because of the
X case being located this contains the
memories of all the agents along with
the Intel a possessed such as new codes
black site locations and who let the
dogs out now the other person after this
X case is a character called Dahlia
Archer We join her in the next scene
meeting with his secretary of state
ironically we can catch her trimming the
Roses dahlias are of course flowers and
they're known for their ability to bloom
when so many others have died she's
masquerading here as the UK Ambassador
but really she's a broker for the
Manticore organization working alongside
the Prime Minister she doesn't mind
accusing the Press on camera of being
foreign assets even if that reporter's
accent yeah worst British accent I've
ever heard mate she's a spy she's the
by getter get the by
Adalia has learned the CIA know where
the X case is and this sets her off on a
mission trying to track it down and
normally when it comes to villains like
this you have the brains behind
everything and then a henchman who
handles all the dirty work in this case
it's Hench men now we meet with a
soldier look there's no way I'm
pronouncing that right so we'll just
call them Anders or davic played by
Roland Miller the twins track down the
case while Citadel on the other side of
this do what they need to do to get
their hands on it too we see Bernard who
has learned of Dalia's meeting and he's
realized that time is short abducting
Mason and his family in the night he
fills in what Citadel actually are
whilst who watch manicor get their hands
on the X case alongside his ex-wife her
wife and their daughter they're hidden
out of the secret location and he starts
to bring Mason back up to speed now we
discover that they're a super spy
organization that was created in the
1930s they went over the heads of each
nation's security network and this was
in order to do things that are best for
the world instead of a specific country
just like how magical have their symbol
on their wrist we also see their tattoos
have been placed on theirs too they
brought down the Berlin walls stopped
Y2K also hacked the PSN store so
everyone got given a free game when it
went back online however someone stole a
list of all their agents which is
similar to the knock list from the first
mission impossible this gave them the
names and locations of their agents
which set up the attack that happened on
the train bounded by eight of the
world's wealthiest families mandicore
launched a global attack to kill all the
Citadel agents that they could find for
this being a worldwide thing this
spin-off series could very much use this
as an event to push their own shows but
we'll see what happens when we learn
more about them now Bernard says they
have to go to New York to get the case
and this takes us in episode 2 which is
shown from Nadia's perspective he
watches he climbs out the river and this
is only to be put in a a misery ball
situation hey abducted and tied to a bed
she ends up killing her captain that but
her memory is unfortunately erased
obviously this is a protocol put in
place in case agents get caught a
compromised as there is the potential
that torture could make them divulge
their secrets leaves are up shit's creek
though however she does leave a note on
her arms saying go to Valencia Asha
whatever comes next this is where she
later ends up with the character
eventually working in Spain no idea what
the Asher could mean I'm guessing that's
the start of a word that we'll find out
later on and this could potentially give
away who the double agent is anyway back
with Mason we see Bernard and his wife
saying I think that we should tell him
she should know it has been said by
Ashley Cummings that her character Abby
is more ahead and meets the eye and it's
possible that there might be something
going on with her that we aren't privy
to though Bernard tracked Mason through
the DNA donation he may have been
keeping his eye on him through using
Abby Abby could be a citadel agent as
well or she may have done something to
her memory so that she could lies his
Sleeper Cell when you're dealing with a
memory they're all lots of things you
can do with it to manipulate characters
so I do think we might get some twists
and turns involving some of the
characters that we think we know look I
don't know my throwing theories out
there based off conversations that are
written to be ambiguous and things have
pieced together from certain interviews
anyway we get the classic Heist scene
with Mason having to go through body
scanners in the building whilst he's
followed by security busting them up we
get some classic Jazz as he makes his
way out but in doing this it alerts
manicor that he's still alive he's also
giving away to get back his memories
however there is just one tiny little
roadblock one of the twins ends up
shooting Bernard through the back in his
vehicle echoing the opening of the
second born movie and a scene that still
me up as they shoot out outside
and we can see the van has the website
neocom on it as of making this video
it's not being registered but I was
hoping we'd get a cool Citadel Easter
egg or something we will check it before
we put this live but yeah at the moment
nothing there and the phrase neocom is
actually a term used to insult the fall
left and it also means neo-communist
which could be the creative team making
fun of the Citadel organization I don't
know mate probably grasping at straws
because I don't think it's as big
overarching political commentary thing
mate it's just a fun spy show yeah
there's no politics or what do you mean
the ambassador of the UK is the bad guy
for sake you take the
and they can't age Mason's memory and
planets crack but he gets a link to the
past with Nadia's location in Valencia
popping up on the X case here we see the
phallus Festival which is held to
commemorate Saint Joseph and Nadia
doesn't seem too interested in those
events eight years ago and to her she
woke up in a strange cabin with a
murdered man on the floor throwing a
knife at her like Bernard did to him we
get a great scene showing Mason trying
to reveal the truth I really think the
show hits a tight pointer moments like
this and though it's not deliberately
dropping jokes all the time there is a
nice undercurrent of humor one of the
twins arrives and this leads to a big
standoff but Nadia regains her memories
and she fights back love watching the
before and after of Nadia getting her
Memories Back and Priyanka does a great
job of bringing the two sides out now we
do get a moment in which she talks about
how she remembers everything and during
this we see several scenes I'm guessing
will be expanded on throughout the
season guess who went through them in
slow-mo though spoilish kervin spoils
and in them we see the train scene from
episode 1 along with with a Detonator
Nadia amazing kissing on the train and
then a shot that we haven't seen before
now he is in a white bathroom and then
we cut to what seems like the living
room of this house with her and Mason
dressed up guessing this is from their
time living together and potentially
Mason Mike had his Memories Back at some
point which will expand upon this the
other vial is smashed there is a
potential that the memories have been
uploaded at the Citadel server and thus
they can be retrieved now in the next
scene we catch Nadia in white camouflage
with other soldiers holding a gun up to
Mason taking place in the woods I'm
guessing that this might be their first
meeting we can catch what look like
Off-Road Jeeps in the scene and in one
of the other shots we can catch the pair
riding together in one continuing on
From This Moment trailers for the series
have shown several parts of the scene
with them clearly working together and
against each other possibly due to Nadia
being a double agent at this moment
where the pair get into a heated
argument together a shot of them in bed
and some light-hearted moments before we
end on a more cryptic one we see Nadia
saying Mason can never find out and this
could be hitting at the secret that
bernardiness wife talked about before
I'm reaching here yeah but whenever I
see stuff like this I tend to wonder
whether it's a pregnancy thing or if
Nadia lost the baby or something along
those lines uh might have pushed Mason
over the edge if she kept it from him
now her getting her Memories Back whilst
Mason doesn't allows him to be a fish
out of water whilst she can kind of fill
in the blanks I'm guessing the next
thing they'll do is reveal Bernard is
actually still alive and they'll have to
rescue him from Dahlia who we see in the
next scene I did get these two episodes
early so I'm not sure if this is in the
final release but at the end there was a
trailer showing what's coming up in the
season they had several parts that
expanded on Nadia's memories and also
clear an occasion that there was an
agent that betrayed Citadel anyway
now I think it would be wild if we
discover that this was actually Mason no
I don't know why they'd put them In
Harm's Way like they did on the train
they might have wanted to take him off
the board though due to him being a
loose end which may be why they were so
surprised to see him alive it's probably
a cliche twist to take it that way and
the trailer does make things look like
Nadia is the one doing it due to the
shot of her holding a gun to Mason being
on screen as this narration takes place
as I said though we see other parts of
this scene including them escaping
together so I don't think it's her she
also remembers everything and therefore
she'd know if she worked for the other
side and probably instantly kill Mason
him not having his memories is the only
thing stopping him from doing it and I
think Nadia would have to wrestle with
whether to eventually Fallen comrades or
spare the man she loves an idea keeping
a secret from Mason could also hand out
what's happened potentially Mason found
this out and it him up so badly
that he decided to switch sides lots of
things we could get on it but we'll put
a lid on it there and that and suit her
you know
I expect you to die
we're close to South the episode if dear
me and I you know what I hope you had
fun going through it and seeing some of
the references that they dropped in the
show hopefully I see you back next week
promise you'll come back and uh let me
know what you thought of this series in
the comment section below we are in
competition right now giving away the
quantumania steelbook to three
subscribers on the 15th of May and all
you have to do to be when the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episodes we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners are on screen right now similar
to you then message me on Twitter at
heavy spoilers you want something else
to watch we've got loads of breakdowns
of Yellowjackets so definitely head over
there right after this Jared's done an
outstanding job wrecking down the series
in there I'm so proud of the guy so yeah
make sure you check them out at the end
of that show if not then hopefully I see
you next time you take care yourself
peace